so did you figure out what you're
dressing up as tomorrow he wants to
dress up as a real guy who murdered nine
people last year oh you're not doing
that
just a costume
you think that guy's still out there
what's up with you and this clown all of
a sudden you're like obsessed they never
found his body what if he decides to
come back here
I wouldn't worry about it wait a minute
aren't you that guy from the costume
shop sir what are you doing it wasn't me
it was covered in blood on his shirt and
his hands when he got here
I'm telling you it was him
right down to the little black dot on
the tip of his nose
you're really weird you know that
I believe him what something really
bad's gonna happen tonight no I know
when Jonathan's lying okay I could hear
it in his voice some things something's
wrong look we're gonna have fun
it's free environment yep
I'm speaking of surprises kids we have a
very special guest with us today all the
way from Miles County please welcome art
the Clown
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign